in a dystopian futuristic New Orleans
something dangerous has been making
rounds in the Underworld a mysterious
man has been giving drug dealers access
to a dangerous and Powerful drug known
as power this is a pill that when
consumed grants the user incredible
superhuman abilities for five minutes as
the drug is distributed among the street
level dealers a man named Newt also gets
a small share fast forward six weeks and
we find ourselves amidst the bustling
streets of the city once again this time
newt's teenage cousin Robin who is also
involved in the drug trade is in a
sticky situation some customers
desperate to get their hands on power
are trying to rob her but just when
things seem to be going wrong Robin is
saved by the appearance of a New Orleans
Police Department's officer Frank shaver
it turns out that Frank is not only a
cop but also one of Robin's regular
buyers meanwhile a former U.S Army Major
named art is on a Relentless pursuit to
track down the distributor of power a
mysterious man known only as biggie his
path ultimately leads him to Newt the
drug dealer from earlier but before art
can interrogate him Newt tragically
meets his demise during a struggle when
he accidentally overdoses on power while
this is happening Frank the police
officer finds himself involved once
again when he thwarts a bank robbery
perpetrated by a criminal who has taken
power but instead of being rewarded for
this he is suddenly suspended for using
the drug in a surprising turn of events
Frank's captain confides in him
revealing that powerful forces within
the government are exerting pressure to
Halt any investigation into power as a
gesture of trust the captain hands Frank
a photograph of the Prime Suspect
believed to be the source of the drug
this is revealed to be art himself while
Frank is figuring it out art kidnaps
Robin and has her lead him to the drug
cartel secret hideout using the deceased
newt's phone at The Hideout the two get
involved in a shootout during the fierce
encounter art sustains gunshot wounds
while dispatching several members of the
cartel but it's during this chaos that
art uncovers a shocking truth power
users all over New Orleans are being
used as unwilling test subjects for the
drug as Arts injuries are tended to by
Robin a bond forms between them art
opens up about his past revealing that
after leaving the military he became a
pawn in the hands of teleos a private
defense contractor taleo subject are to
experiments aimed at creating superhuman
abilities furthermore art explains that
his daughter Tracy was born with powers
without ever having taken power herself
sadly Tracy was abducted by Wallace a
teleos operative with this information
out there art and Robin joined forces to
uncover the truth behind the drug and
its mysterious new Distributors once and
for all as they investigate the matter
further they come upon a new piece of
information the main figure behind the
distribution of the drug to people like
newt The Man known as biggie is said to
be hosting a special promotion for the
drug using their determination art and
Robin find their way into this promotion
which is revealed to be a private
determination showcasing the pill's
incredible capabilities and to make
matters worse this event is to take
place near the Superdome during a very
important game as the stadium is slowly
filled by the local Saint teams fans art
and Robin observed the secret ceremony
while undercover biggie boldly claims
that power represents the next stage of
human evolution harnessing the
extraordinary powers derived from
animals like chameleons or the Wolverine
frog with too much time already wasted
art confronts biggie in the middle of
the ceremony and tried to make him talk
at gunpoint desperate for answers
through this intense interrogation art
discovers crucial information about a
ship called the Genesis however their
encounter is disrupted by the arrival of
Frank who has been tracking other power
users to this very demonstration in an
effort to escape the rapidly escalating
situation biggie ingests a power pill
himself forcing art Robin and Frank to
escape the ensuing chaos amidst the
chaos art seizes the opportunity and
eliminates biggie causing a tremendous
explosion that completely destroys their
surroundings the aftermath finds Frank
apprehending art and Reporting the
situation to his captain art seizes this
opportunity to shed light on the truth
he reveals that the power epidemic
sweeping New Orleans is in fact a
large-scale testing phase aimed at
stabilizing the drug by using the lower
class drug users as unwilling test
subjects moreover art discloses that
Tracy his daughter is the very source of
the new Drug's extraordinary abilities
with persuasive arguments and an air of
conviction art successfully convinces
Frank that his captain is acting under
the control of teleos in a daring move
art orchestrates his own capture by
teleos deliberately putting himself at
their mercy so that he has a chance to
sneak into the heart of the conspiracy
and just as he had hoped he has
subsequently transported aboard the
Genesis the vessel that was mentioned by
Biggie and is at the heart of the
situation while art is being transported
the other two members of the team Frank
and Robin also try to infiltrate the
formidable Genesis and as they are doing
it they once again encounter art who has
managed to convince one of the guards to
set him free reunited the trip moved
forward through the ship's maze-like
corridors where they finally happen upon
the person they have been looking for as
the tension mounts Frank and art
confront this man who is the one and
only Wallace a formidable operative of
teleos and the three engage in a fierce
confrontation in a parallel Quest Robin
driven by her love for her father and
sister locates Tracy so she can reunite
her with art since she couldn't save her
own family all of this concludes in a
moment of Celebration as art is reunited
with his daughter who is up till now
being used to develop the new Power pill
the fate of New Orleans and the lives of
its inhabitants hang in the balance as
this team of unlikely Heroes confronts
their adversaries head-on their
Collective determination pushing them
closer to the truth amidst the chaos and
Desperation our protagonists find
themselves cornered their escape plans
thrown into disarray Dr Gardner The
Mastermind behind project power captures
Robin holding her hostage and demanding
Tracy in return for Robin's life the
stakes have never been Higher undeterred
by the dire circumstances art steps
forward having taken the pill in a
last-ditch attempt to save his Newfound
family he Taps into the abilities of a
pistol shrimp an animal with an
incredibly strong propositional punch
and unleashes a devastating Force
against Gardner and her men in a
climactic showdown are its extraordinary
powers proved to be the key to ending
Gardner's reign of terror however this
Valiant act comes at a great cost as art
sacrifices his own life in the process
in a twist of fate Tracy empowered by
her own unique abilities harnesses her
extraordinary powers to breathe life
back into Art's fading existence a
glimmer of hope shines through as art is
resurrected defying All Odds together
they rally and seize the opportunity to
escape the clutches of Genesis leaving
behind a destroyed Genesis in the end of
telios Frank driven by a desire for just
sets his sights on exposing the truth
behind project power to the Press he
intends to shed light on the nefarious
operations and unveil the dark secrets
that have plagued New Orleans meanwhile
art forever marked by the battle's
fought and the sacrifices made makes a
Bittersweet decision to forge A New Path
in a gesture of Goodwill and compassion
art and trusts Robin with his truck and
a substantial sum of money the bag full
of funds is meant to support her
mother's medical needs a symbol of Art's
unwavering care and concern for those he
leaves behind he imparts to Robin a
profound message urging her to embrace
the greatness that resides within her
own being as art and Tracy embark on
their next Journey they finally taste
the sweet Freedom they have fought so
fiercely to obtain the weight of their
past struggles begins to lift replaced
by a newfound sense of Liberation and
possibility meanwhile Robin forever
changed by the tumultuous events she has
witnessed embarks on a new chapter in
her life embracing her passion for music
she discovers her calling as a rapper
setting forth on a path that promises to
be as vibrant and dynamic as the city
she calls home click on one of the
videos on the screen now
[Music]